Les ordinateurs quantiques sont là pour résoudre des problèmes qui ne peuvent pas être traités
par les ordinateurs classiques — des choses
comme trouver les bons matériaux pour permettre
la capture du carbone, pour vraiment
mener le combat contre le changement climatique, pour concevoir
des engrais plus efficaces qui
ne nuisent pas à la terre tout en maintenant
la chaîne alimentaire dont on a besoin pour nourrir le monde
Il y a aussi des questions fondamentales sur la façon dont notre univers
est assemblé et sur le comportement de la matière à l'échelle atomique
et subatomique que nous devons comprendre
C'est la prochaine frontière
Prenons un domaine de recherche déjà en cours :
la recherche de nouvelles batteries
Les batteries ont transformé nos vies en nous permettant de transporter
des ordinateurs et des smartphones
mais il reste encore beaucoup à faire — les batteries sont essentielles
à notre avenir énergétique propre
que ce soit pour alimenter les voitures électriques ou vraiment
développer les énergies renouvelables
On a besoin d'une chimie fondamentalement différente
pour créer les batteries
de demain — l'informatique quantique
nous permettrait de regarder efficacement à l'intérieur de la batterie
pendant ses réactions très complexes, pour nous permettre de
réfléchir à de nouveaux matériaux
et à la structure des batteries qui seront nécessaires
pour alimenter la prochaine génération d'appareils
Comment y arriver ? En construisant les dispositifs les plus avancés du monde
et une plateforme de développement
en la mettant à la disposition du monde entier
C'est seulement en travaillant ensemble maintenant
qu'on pourra résoudre les problèmes auxquels on sera confrontés
ensemble dans le futur.